all right breaking tonight in six days
any americans any of our allied partners
that are inside afghanistan will be
marked for dead subjugated to the will
of the terrorists now running the new
islamic emirate of afghanistan and your
commander-in-chief has now humiliated
this entire country and is being bullied
into submission by the terrorists the
taliban
we are currently on a pace to finish by
august the 31st the sooner we can finish
the better
i can tell you there's no way we can
humanly get all of our american citizens
and afghan partners out of country by
that time it sounds like you're still
working on our august 31st deadline
we are absolutely still aiming towards
the end when future american soldiers
have to go back in to deal with the
problem
and deal with the incompetence of this
administration
how many are going to die either he's
senile or he's in denial but either way
it's reckless for our country and this
disaster is taking place is his
responsibility why can't you just say
the number
barbara i think we're just going to
leave it at several thousand right now
and i understand that's not a satisfying
answer to you
[Music]
it's sickening i can't believe this is
happening in our country today and
particularly after the decision made
today and what we heard today he will
have blood
on his hands americans held hostage
behind enemy lines day 10.
all right we are now day 10 of americans
held hostage trapped behind enemy lines
and clearly president biden he's letting
the taliban call all the shots he will
not commit to keeping u.s forces past
the taliban's august 31st deadline he
will not commit to ensuring the rescue
of all of our citizens and our afghan
partners that we promised we would get
out if this day ever came he has no idea
how many americans or how many of our
allies are still trapped in kabul
controlled by the taliban or elsewhere
in the country he doesn't know exactly
how many americans have already even
been evacuated and now fox news is
reporting that the u.s military has
started withdrawing from afghanistan so
today the u.s embassy in kabul issued an
alert it was later deleted about 30
minutes later calling on all americans
to leave afghanistan or they are on
their own
your government
wow just get to the airport they say use
your best judgment they say trust that
the terrorists the taliban will ensure
your safe passage
but
was we've reported for more than a week
they're also saying there is no safe
passage watch with your own eyes
we are stranded at home we can get to
the airport when we try to get to the
airport we either get beaten up or we're
afraid for our lives taliban are going
door to door looking for um
for people who has
worked with the u.s government for of
course for the u.s citizens so our lives
are an extreme danger
we get more
of uh news to
stay put than to be told that you're
going to be evacuated this is not
this is not comforting at all because we
don't know if we're gonna make it out
that was a fellow american citizen now
hopelessly trapped behind enemy lines
ostensibly a hostage to the goodwill of
the terrorist group the taliban the
airport is completely encircled they
have covered the entire perimeter the
taliban they control who gets in they
control who gets out and now the taliban
has apparently blocking saying they're
blocking all access to the airport for
any afghan citizens that means people
that may have helped us the last 20
years biden he just signed the death
certificates of every afghan that in
fact has helped the us in the last 20
years and apparently they even have
access to computer data so that these
people will be hunted down they will be
murdered their families will be murdered
joe apparently today seemed to care less
today in what was a tone-deaf speech
delivered over four hours late biden
spoke about infrastructure and voting
rights and then eventually got around to
the crisis that is afghanistan but of
course took no questions after all he
may get yelled at he doesn't want to get
in trouble a slight improvement over
last wednesday when he refused to
address afghanistan at all and that was
a speech about vaccine boosters biden is
living in an alternate reality tonight
and so is his clueless press secretary
because today
gensake referred to the ongoing
evacuation in kabul as a huge success
but the people on the ground in kabul
beg to differ jen you might want to
watch circle back and learn take a look
i would say that this is now on track
peter to be the largest airlift in u.s
history i'm sure that if they capture me
they will kill me
like me there are 100 people this is
called the wrong policy of the united
states when i went there they were just
whipping people left and right so i got
whipped and i got really scared i came
back
[Music]
bringing american citizens out it is
bringing our afghan partners out it is
bringing allies out i worked
half of my life
with the u.s
and now they left me behind i served my
basically one third of my life with the
us government and now i'm not even able
to save my own family my own blood so no
i would not say that is that anything
but a success i'm an american
rescue
evacuate
take me home that's how jen and biden's
defined success more than 20 people have
died during this so-called evacuation
that we know of countless others have
been brutally beaten by taliban fighters
women children have been gassed they've
been whipped they've been stabbed many
evacuees have been forced to pay tens of
thousands of dollars to hire private
military contractors to escort them to
the airport and just yesterday sakinsaki
angrily claimed that it was
irresponsible to say americans are
stranded in afghanistan but just 24
hours later she said that of course some
americans will be left behind after the
august 31st deadline
you've got to be kidding we're going to
leave americans behind
you decide
most of the criticism is not of leaving
afghanistan it's the way that he has
ordered it to happen
by pulling the troops before getting
these americans who are now stranded
does he have a sense of that first of
all i think it's irresponsible to say
americans are stranded they are not if
one u.s citizen was suddenly discovered
you know saying hey i really want to get
out and i'm stuck who knows where
somewhere in afghanistan or in kabul
he's got any problem would this trigger
a
diplomatic military
or hands-on deck type thing to get that
person out whatever the date
our commitment continues to be to us
citizens if they want to leave we will
help get them out
again we expect there could be some
that's being stranded that was aired on
the fox news channel that woman that we
just played jen sadly just one of many
contradictions from the bible
administration first they told everyone
just shelter in place and they said make
your way to the airport but we cannot
ensure your safety but we trust that the
taliban will give you safe passage then
they said don't come to the airport on
saturday it's too dangerous now
apparently anyone who is not out by
august 31st you are on your own maybe
the worst part of all is we could have
easily prevented all of this chaos and
all of this carnage in april joe biden
announced that he would draw down all
american troops during uh peak taliban
fighting season in the summer
now why so why you want to do a victory
lap i don't know on september 11th i
have no earthly idea joe in may we saw
the taliban offensive beginning look at
this timeline pay close attention it
could have and should have been stopped
then dead then
by june the fighting was taking place in
20 of the 34 provinces throughout the
country joe biden ignored it all by july
the taliban controlled a large portion
of afghanistan and was picking up steam
and joe was telling us how great afghan
forces were on july 2nd u.s forces
the dumbest decision up to up to speed
uh up to that point withdrew from pogrom
airfield leaving kabul our embassy and
thousands of americans totally
completely defenseless against the
taliban invasion and still they didn't
get them out by august 1st the afghan
army was in tatters the taliban was
closing in on kabul joe biden did not
reverse course he stayed on vacation he
never retake was able to retake bagram
airport base uh he did not create a
perimeter around key us assets he did
not just secure or destroy the billions
and billions and billions of dollars of
military equipment and blackhawk
helicopters that he left behind that was
short-sighted that was pretty dumb there
was no plan ever in place whatsoever and
two weeks later the taliban then marched
right to the center of kabul biden still
did nothing except stay on vacation and
since then let's see the dutch the
french the british well they've sent
troops behind enemy lines into kabul to
extract their citizens with their
special forces and their paratroopers
and our military is under strict orders
not to leave the airport americans were
left to pen for themselves but the dutch
protected their citizens their troops
went behind enemy lines the french the
british but not american troops this is
utter humiliation on the world stage and
worse
thousands of americans and thousands of
our friends and allies they're likely to
be murdered soon by the taliban that i
was in full control in fact some are
already being tortured some are already
being murdered even obama's homeland
security secretary jay johnson honestly
warning that the situation in kabul will
get a lot worse before it ever gets
better now joe biden needs to grow a
spine answer some basic pivotal
important questions he needs to be
honest for a change and cut the crap
with the spin with jen saki joe will you
ensure that every american is out before
you leave afghanistan why would you
leave one american behind joe
will you pledge not to leave a single
american behind
do we have special forces on the ground
who are
are you willing to send them to rescue
american citizens that are telling the
news media they can't get to the airport
will you commit to extracting our afghan
partners who we promised to get out if
this day ever came and you said last
week you would get out and for all the
refugees who are rescued what is being
done to vet them we want specifics in
other words so we don't have a member of
isis or al qaeda or isis k sneaking into
our country and bringing harm to
americans here and the most important
question is this joe
why didn't you evacuate americans in may
in june and july
watching and knowing the taliban was
taking the
entire country in record time
there's zero excuse for that there is no
good answer you failed in what is a
surrender but tonight let me be clear
the president can still change course
we have less than seven days now he
can't fight back he can put in the best
military on the face of this earth and
send them like the dutch and the french
and the brits and extract american
citizens he can make it clear to the
taliban that if they hurt a single
american the consequences for them will
be dire and he needs to mean it and
sadly tonight i have zero fate biden is
capable of ever doing the right thing
he's nothing but a career politician no
integrity no morals no beliefs and
totally completely utterly cognitively
out of it the only thing biden seems to
care about is joe biden and those close
to joe biden making money and now come
august the 31st well that's seven days
from now i fear that those left behind
will face
certain death hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else